here are my three adrenal fatigue tips
so if you are suffering with your
adrenals being out of whack because of
your stress levels we know that the
adrenal glands sit on top of the kidneys
and they can run into difficulties
especially when you have something
called pregnant alone steel and what
that means is that your body is going to
preferentially take all of that
cholesterol that your body has to make
cortisol your stress hormone and now
you're not going to be making your other
hormones properly like your estrogen and
guys for the testosterone so my tip
number one is decrease your overall
inflammation inflammation is going to
worsen your leptin resistance and worsen
this pregnant lone steel situation the
second tip is fix your leptin resistance
which means stopping eating right before
bed see that early morning sunlight and
do some cold therapy that will help as
well and the third tip take some
ashwagandha it's a great adaptogen great
for that stress and for the adrenals
follow for more natural health tubes